Speaker 1: All right, let's try. Oh, I don't know.
How about. Isaiah from Arka, Philadelphia. I don't
know what that means, Izia, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: Oh, David, can you hear me? Yes,
I can. Actually, so there's a there's a town
called Arkadelphia. It's where I go to college
is not actually where I am right now.
Speaker 1: Arkadelphia,
very good. What state is that?
Speaker 5: Is the state of Arkansas.
Speaker 1: Very good. Arkadelphia,
Arkansas. I'm learning a lot here.
Speaker 5: And so I just had and I wanted to
get your your thought on this. Yeah. About
conspiracy theories and so maybe a safe way
of talking about them rhetorically. OK, so
I'm trying to think about the best way to
to get to this. But kind of as an example,
though, there's the absolutely
ludicrous ones based in no
truth whatsoever that the people that believe
in them are never going to not find a reason
to believe in them. And obviously those should
be criticized. But then there's ones like the
Eppstein theories where personally and I don't
know what you believe in this, but personally, I
think Ockham's Razor says that it's it seems that
there's more evidence saying that there's that
the cause of death is not what is being stated.
Speaker 1: I have not I have not been convinced of
that. We did a segment where we looked at a bunch
of claims made by a forensic forensic pathologist.
And if you just listen to the claims and
accept them, it certainly sounds that way.
But then when I actually researched each
claim, like, for example, one claim was
the hyoid bone never gets broken in in a hanging
suicide. But then you research that and it's like,
oh, actually, half the time it does get
broken in a hanging suicide. So I you know,
when I looked more into it, I came away not
feeling like it was. I think the circumstantial
questions are much stronger than some of that
stuff. But anyway, maybe it's not really the point
Speaker 5: that cases as an example. So I as
you said, like so if I saw the evidence, I would
be willing to change my mind. Yeah, I would say
based on the evidence I presented various times,
my question is, how do we safely discuss one
type of Weich suspicious thing that maybe is not
accepted as mainstream, but want
to investigate and think about what
Speaker 1: way is it unsafe? I mean,
when you say how can we safely do it,
where would the lack of safety come from?
Speaker 5: So I guess what what I mean is that
and I was just using EPSO in this one particular
example. Yeah, but. When you talk about so
like there's MK Ultra, which was a very, very
real thing, used to be a conspiracy theory,
a lot of people that talk about these
kinds of things online, these communities,
they're toxic communities that because
one thing may have some truth to it,
drags people in the other conspiracies. And so how
do we kind of talk about one thing that we think?
I think there may be something more to this. What,
to look into it without being dragged into the.
Total nonsense.
Speaker 1: Here is the reality, the noncom,
there are people who are just conspiracists, they
love conspiracies and we've talked about them with
experts on the show. Those people are rarely just
going to say, let me examine this one thing and
just go where the facts take me, because they are,
by their nature, conspiracists. The way to safely
do it is just for non conspiracists to evaluate
all of these things. Right. Like, I don't consider
myself a conspiracist. I don't just fall down.
I don't think, hey, you know what? One lab leak,
no evidence of a bioweapon, that it
was developed and released on purpose.
It's plausible. And all along I've said it
should be looked into whether the virus was being
researched in a lab and it accidentally leaked and
someone got scratched and infected or whatever.
OK, I'm not falling for flat earth. I'm not doing
Covanta vaccine conspiracy. You know, if people
like you and I, the safe way to do it would be
for people like you and I to just examine these
things and to go where the evidence takes us. And
it I can say for myself, and it sounds like you're
the same way, you don't just get dragged down any
conspiracy path just because someone mentions it.
OK, but important question, I'm going to
move on because I do have so many people
waiting, why don't we go today? Let's go to
Joseph from Seattle. Joseph, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Stand back and stand by, Joseph.
Speaker 1: All right, no, Joseph,
today, not off to a great start